this is another episode of frog zebra
nation
crazy
[Music]
hell yeah dude hell yeah it's
congratulations
it's another episode of congratulations
dude we're doing it why is this
thing over the desk we started out
already [ __ ] it all up ah
yeah dude it is what it is but we gotta
go make this go under it we gotta make
that go under the desk because when it
goes over over the desk so [ __ ] how i'm
doing it when it goes over the desk it
[ __ ]
pulls my head and when it pulls my head
i look so [ __ ] so either way i looked a
bit so really
we had to just make sure
it was um
it was a [ __ ] moment but whatever dude
sometimes you have subbitch moments and
then you get through them and it's all
good uh but we're having a good time and
uh i feel like we're already firing on
all syllables and um and everything is
good are you did you just turn the
volume down or something
why would you do that isn't that crazy
you couldn't hear it
oh we'll turn hers down but why would
you turn mine down
crazy right wow let's yeah we got it
good now i'm good now what we want to do
is not touch mine right
remember when p diddy would be all like
turn me up in the headphones or like
mace would be like turn me up into
headphones and then every rapper was
like turn me up into headphones people
would start [ __ ] freestyles off like
that and people would be like there's no
headphones
um i'm keeping it really fashionable and
nice i got that [ __ ] pleated shirt on
be more memorable because if somebody
can't remember you that's [ __ ] your
fault and this is what you do to
represent that notion we represent
notions all day long if you are a cult
member for congratulations meet me at
the [ __ ] log cabin one day so uh it's
very beautiful it's very nice and it
[ __ ] scoops it's very cool i got that
[ __ ] chain on like i'm like i'm
basically you know carrying on the torch
for dmx dude when i saw dmx had that
short chain in 1999 i was like i can't
wait to [ __ ] grow up to wear that one
day
so he keeps it real
i drink i drink coffee and i just keep
drinking it and nobody can stop me my
therapist says maybe you know you drink
too much coffee and i say maybe and then
i [ __ ] go to sleep and then the next
day we do it all over again
so that's what's up
um
you know it's uh whatever day it is
whatever you're listening to it um and
we love being here for you guys and by
we i mean me let's just jump right into
it um
this is the greatest [ __ ]
this was on gawker i really don't know
much about gawker to me gawker sounds
like something that is like not
i don't know if it's legit journalism or
what i have no [ __ ] idea
but uh
this was a real interview it becomes
normal this is a real interview about a
[ __ ] toast the swing of it gets it
becomes normal
i mean after you've seen a haunted
toaster
let's stop it right there let's stop it
right there let's stop it right there
haunted toaster are never two words that
should go together
okay
because toasters only do one thing and
that's make make bread hot they make
bread crispy that's what they do know
what they don't do possess ya
no they don't do go
a toaster is one thing and that's a
toaster okay but let's keep going dude
let's keep listening guy looks like
francis ford coppola all good now
there's a [ __ ] elbow of a chick let's
see when they zoom out what she looks
like
we heard a q-tip her head is the top of
a q-tip or the bottom of a q-tip because
if you turn a q-tip around it's the same
[ __ ] it's one of those things like race
car when you take race car you flip all
the letters around it still spells race
car or toot
this lady is basically the [ __ ] human
equivalent of toot
so
uh why was this a hairdo by the way in
the [ __ ] what was it the early 80s
why was this a hairdo dude just that one
big poof
just a big [ __ ] poof it looked like
right before the atom bomb got re where
you really started to worry you know
like you'd see an explosion be like whoa
that's big and then you're like wait a
second oh that's what her hair was it
just got that big before it [ __ ]
mushroom clouded
um
so yeah so that's what it looks like
let's find out her name her name is
going to be something
i am the devil
let's go a little bit back because when
you
do
a when you play something and you stu
and you stop it and then you talk about
a little bit and then you play it on a
podcast and then you don't realize
you're at the part where the ladies said
i am the devil you gotta go back you
gotta go back and you gotta say what the
[ __ ] she was talking about
my bad for talking sometimes you know
sometimes
you know what i mean that happens
especially like in relationships when
i'm with kristen a lot of times we'll be
talking and i'll be saying something and
then she'll talk over me
and then i'll be like oops right because
the sentence never ends in my and that
was the last word i said right so if
that was the last word i said my
then what happened then i guess maybe i
got cut off right and we shouldn't be
doing that should we and then she goes
chris and i say okay so can i go back
and she says okay and then guess what i
forgot what the [ __ ] i was gonna say yes
dude
yes had to lay down the law in the
process of laying down the law he forgot
what he said which is fine because you
need to lay down the law a lot in a
relationship
all good
but it's real love
real love oh
i'm searching for a real life
someone
whatever real love
just [ __ ]
i could be in that group
i was six when it came out so uh what
did she say you heard i am the devil
they heard the toaster voice did the
devil have
um a very low voice i'd say sounded like
eli wallach
wow dude the toaster had a very low
voice that sounded like eli wallach
the cool thing about this podcast is
when i wake up in the morning i never
know
about the sentences that will be coming
out of my mouth later on in the day
and
the one that shocked me so far
is
the toaster had a low voice that sounded
like eli wallach but i ended up saying
it if you had woke me up this morning
and said hey chris
guess what your guess what you're going
to either say or hear today and i said
what and you said
the toaster had a low voice that sounded
like eli wallach i would think one thing
it must be podcast day
it must be podcast day and it is
who's eli wallace anyway i got to look
him up eli
i definitely heard
the name before wow imagine the toaster
eli wallach when did he die
why we lived long well he lived in to be
99.
what does he sound like
let's see eli wallace voice
here we go
eli wallace why he's always plays the
bad guy okay so he played a toaster i
have a feeling that the first imprint
you make on
him
as a child i used to see these movies
where the heaven was heating no are you
at all concerned that today people are a
little bit
aware of what violence in films is doing
and here you are good bad and the ugly
as mean and vicious a performance and a
thesis as as could be imagined yes but
you see when you say violence this is
how we sound i don't think there's
anything more violent than what's
happening in the world today yeah okay
but that's not the question
let's talk about that well okay that's
what eli wallace sounded like dude
maybe some subway the metro yeah it took
20 minutes this is what the toasters are
after i finished working i had my makeup
on i'm sitting in the subway not even
that evil hey toast is done
all right so let's go back to this thing
i gotta [ __ ] let's go back to this
thing here let's think it let's see what
the [ __ ] this lady's getting at
saved any of this satanic toast yes i
did save it because i wanted to be sure
that somebody else would see it now this
one
can you see that richard
see
ah
the toast
has an imprint that says satan lives
uh
just eat it
dude
it says satan lives
she did it
hey june o'brien
you did it
hey you're trying to trick us that
satan's in the toaster also how about
the ego you gotta have
to think even if she was being serious
the ego you gotta have to think my
toaster is haunted but it's not just a
demon
satan's at my house
that's unreal
to be like my house is the one that
satan comes to
what about his
you know what i mean
what are they called evil archangels
what about the [ __ ] fallen angels
what about them huh your house is so
[ __ ] dope with the with the
with the
uh periwinkle wallpaper satan showed up
to that one you think satan doesn't like
comfort
satan is the [ __ ] dude in the underworld
sorry god but you know what i mean when
i was a kid i used to say swear words
and [ __ ] and then i would go sorry god
i'd look up in the air and i'd say sorry
god as if god was up there looking down
at me like this
i'll send [ __ ] satan down to your
toaster dude
that was my ocd
people somebody asked me the other day
when did you know you had ocd and i said
well it [ __ ] for sure flared its head
when it was when i was in my early 20s
and he said oh really and i said yeah
but there were always signs
and he was like like what and should
have said that whenever i said a swear
word i looked up and said sorry god
now that's just as ridiculous as
thinking
satan's cooking your sandwiches
but
however
remember when you used to write an essay
in high school and you just it needed to
be a certain amount of words and you
just every other sentence was however so
you'd be like [ __ ] that's 16 however
i got [ __ ] 16 words right there
i would do it and uh
when i exhaled my nose snot came out but
then it went back in it was like when
jeff bezos went to space he got up there
a little bit and then whoa okay cool and
then dipped out that's what my [ __ ]
boogie did
this is clicking around
um
so uh my my audio's clicking around yes
that's amazing so um
so yeah so satan lives with this
it's just the ego people have to think
that like for even for me as as a
six-year-old when i would say sorry god
or even as an 11-year-old to say sorry
god to [ __ ] be like okay but that's
something an eleven-year-old does but
this woman is a full-fledged adult
saying hey
to believe let's say she does believe
this she's not trying to trick people
which i think she is trying to trick
people
to think that we're not the
like we're such big idiots that we don't
think that
you do that you did that and tried to
trick us as one thing but to if we say
we you thought we believed you
still what about your [ __ ] ego that
satan is at your house
also satan lives that's how he's gonna
say it in your toast
you think satan can't pick up a [ __ ]
marker you think satan can't [ __ ]
find where your lipstick is and write it
on your mirror
he's gonna he's gonna burn your bread
he's gonna burn it in your bread dude
it's so annoying when people think that
ghosts and [ __ ] are real i got a buddy
that literally was like i said to him i
was like do you believe in that [ __ ] all
that paranormal [ __ ] and he says oh 100
and i was like why and he said oh dude i
[ __ ] cause i know it does because
because it happened to me once and i
said really something irrefutable and he
was like 100
and i said well what is it and i said
and dude keep it short
and he said okay i'll try i swear to god
it took an hour kristen he was doing
voice notes because i was like don't
text is going to take too long he was
doing voice notes kristen at 45 minutes
and she was like what the [ __ ] what are
you listening to it was him telling me
how one time he moved into an apartment
in [ __ ] los angeles and like
his
his car had a boot on it and then a tire
was missing and then like it looked like
there was burnt wallpaper and then hair
in his bathtub and he thought it was the
guy that used to live here that [ __ ]
killed himself
and i'm like that's not your beautiful
irrefutable evidence man
this [ __ ] never happened to me where's
my toast where's my satan toast
where's my lipstick on the mirror that
says watch out watch behind you where's
all that [ __ ] where's the lights even
flickering dude
it's always explainable by electricity
or science
just terrible is the toaster still
possessed
i i
we still have trouble off and on with it
yes
oh she's cooking toast now here we go
for the people that listen
and it doesn't work of course it's not
working now that they won't even go down
i just want that it seems to be aware
it seems to be aware
it first of all you're not it's like a
baby okay if you start talking about
satan you gotta say him or at least her
you know i don't know what he identifies
as or what it but you don't say it it's
like a baby dude you don't say hey did
it come yet and you're like what yeah
your baby
he you mean
you can't just it's aware if you're
saying it you know it's a goddamn
toaster
i'm a good lawyer dude
she's on the stand so
correct me if i'm i'm wrong you were you
were saying um
ma'am uh with the with the puffy uh
q-tip head you
you were saying that it uh it was aware
right meaning meaning what
meaning the toaster right okay but the
toaster if it's possessed it would be
who it would be satan okay so
satan is uh
is what
i don't know he's like he's i'm sorry he
is
yeah okay so if he's in the toaster then
he's the
well yeah but i and you called it it
well yeah but i rest my case no further
questions boom got it right there
technicality
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
dude the toaster went bonkers and
[ __ ] wow it really okay so she set it
up there's flames on the toaster that
they come up
and she goes oh
why does that happen are you hearing
that cut out all right then it's my [ __ ]
and she goes oh
why have you kept this toaster why
i love when somebody
puts somebody's name
in an answer that they're about to give
you know like if you're like if kristen
would say
chris why did you do that and i said
well kristin
i would
already be in trouble do you know what i
mean
and if she did it to me well chris i
would know
i was in trouble either way i'm in
trouble you know
but she says well richard i'll tell you
let's see what she says
well richard
you know when all is said and done
it makes good toast
dude
you know how everyone's like what's
wrong with the world now we're headed to
[ __ ] extinction
it's been like this
you think june o'brien's new
she been around
well when all said and done you know
yeah i know it's possessed but it makes
good
good toast know it first of all there's
so many there's how many of alls are
there i think three first of all
no it doesn't
because we saw the toast and it was
burnt to [ __ ]
all right
now
second of all
i'm just gonna go to third of all
because there is a second of all but
third of all is the most crazy
how good
does your toast have to be
for you to allow satan in your home
i mean am i missing something here
toast is toast right
like nobody ever eats toast
and actually thinks
well [ __ ]
that's some good toast right toast is
pretty much
you know the deal from jump
hey here's bread you want me to toast it
sure
you already know you got it locked on
it's not like a [ __ ] sandwich it's
not like it it's not like a
a [ __ ]
pizza domino's is different than the
[ __ ] place you're gonna go down the
street i don't know what it's gonna it's
toast it's [ __ ] you could take a
match to bread it's the same [ __ ]
thing
and this lady
is like well this toast though
well this toast though that's why
yes
satan's here and it's stressful i don't
know if my whole house is gonna burst
into flames like that toaster just did
and i don't know if my son and daughter
are going to live past however old they
are right now because satan may be in
them now
currently
but god damn
this toast
here's the second of all
say you're eating the t say it's the
first time you notice something's janky
or [ __ ] up
or bales of bub has something to do
with your [ __ ] toaster right
the toast comes up
and you literally see it and imprinted
in the toast it's just a middle finger
just right to you or it says satan lives
or like you know [ __ ] god sorry god
and you look at it and your heart is
beaten
you try it
you eat it anyway i'll tell you what
maybe but not if you're june o'brien
and
furthermore
how many times does it happen until
you're like all right well [ __ ] it i
want toast i'm saying you don't eat it
like if i made toast and satan lives
popped out of my [ __ ] thing
and
i don't eat it i just think okay i'm
just gonna pick a new piece of bread and
then eat that but say you made more
toast and then it comes out satan lives
satan still lives satan's still living
by the way by the way satan's still in
your toaster there's all the things that
at what point are you like [ __ ] it i
need toast and you eat it no you just
get a new toaster so she is lying for
sure you know it
[ __ ] yeah i'm a good lawyer hey boyd
matson nbc news boca raton florida and
it happened in florida boy that's odd
florida bin janky is [ __ ]
florida stays janky in this [ __ ]
oh boy
if you like this [ __ ] subscribe to our
youtube it helps i saw a guy on twitch
the other day and he was just like
subscribe to the youtube we ain't
signing we ain't we we ain't leaving
until we hit [ __ ] this many followers
and the and and people were just he
people were just signing up on youtube
he had a count it was like ding ding
ding ding ding and everyone was just
subscribing subscribe to youtube he was
saying it while he was eating like fruit
by the foot he was and there was a guy
with a crutch in the background and then
another guy who was just like standing
there in his head with his hands in his
pockets and everyone was just like
signing up and [ __ ] subscribing and
subscribing and it's just like jesus
christ is this just how you gotta be
so [ __ ] man subscribe to my youtube
if you like it [ __ ] gently brush up
against that like button
if you love it turn on them bell
notifications buy a hat for that bell
notification do whatever man
or sign up to my patreon you know
patreon.com we love it
we love it dude we put out a new segment
called review mode it's out there it
comes out bi-weekly and it's um
and it's uh i think i think we're
putting them out fridays but
second episode it came out the other day
or is coming out i don't remember but
anyway go to my patreon um
yeah dude it's uh
june o'brien man
this was the [ __ ] what was the other
one you sent me
um
you know my toaster sounded like eli
wallach
here is will someone just help on
youtube it's titled
hello
hey hey look at that she couldn't look
more like june o'brien and this was
three years ago this lady has always
existed she's like the vampire
of [ __ ] light white ladies and and
there's so many of them
you have some in your family they just
pop up every now and then and they wear
those sleeveless [ __ ] things
with their grandma arms that flat that
are flabby you know
you know those flabby grandma arms my
buddies got flabby grandma arms and i
said dude your arms are so ugly they
look like flabby grandma arms and we
laughed so hard dude and that's what
it's like being a guy
two girls together could never do that
to each other
if a girl walked up to another girl and
they were friends and they said hey
what's up with that [ __ ] inner tube
around your belly that friendship's over
if a guy said it to a guy they get
closer
and that's the truth i only speak the
truth dude
i don't wear this dmx chain for nothing
my name is lisa and white whitner
my name is lisa and white white whittler
white
i just moved here because i'm getting a
divorce
and it's not final till september 18th
my husband will not give me any money
not one penny
people always like to say that help me
not one penny my husband won't help me
my dad marlon lee whitmer he's a
minister
won't help me
my stepmother won't help me
my mother passed away seven years ago
she won't help me
she's dead
she's in [ __ ] june o'brien's toaster
my dad and annie hockhausen making
people up
they wrote at very front people making
up the sentence my dad and annie
hawkhousen
wrote
letters
are my parents okay annie's my stepmom
so many
people
i'm not quite sure why i'm here or what
i'm doing ah
well no [ __ ] neither away
you're just naming people if i was the
[ __ ] guy on the other side of it i'd
be like well so far you're just naming
people
order in the court order order in the
court she's naming too many people
jim jim hacksaw jim duggan
just goes on to wwf people
brett the hitman heart
wrote there's a reason
hacksaw duggan
my lawyer is just entitled still naming
people unreal dude this is like that dmx
song when he was like about three
quiches and cam lisa
were you just talking about all the
women he slept with
dang dang wait what was it what's that
song
is that what these [ __ ] want
crass
what these [ __ ] want from i saw i
heard the radio engine edit edit radio
edit of that i said this before in the
pockets but and he's and he's uh
sincerely and it sincerely was what
these what these people want from
somebody
just don't even play that song at that
point you know it's like takes the sting
out of it
what these people want from somebody
just driving along the 10 freeway like
what come on give me a [ __ ] break
dude really
somebody let me know
what these people want from somebody
just so vague
also did she say her [ __ ] lawyer's
name was just entitled she's definitely
making it up
hi i'm just entitled are you [ __ ]
kidding me
give me that and those clothes whatever
you're wearing these are mine now
what the [ __ ] did he just walk out of
the grocery store without paying yes i'm
just entitled
i don't know if you've ever heard of him
well we have now
wow dramatic pause i'm moving down to
texas soon hey lady to help okay hell
lady the lady this is me while she's
doing it children in texas lady
very loving parent lady why are you a
very very very loving parent i have a
very 20 year old daughter okay she's
going to college at saint ambrose you're
just named another person
college lady you just made up a
colleague
elizabeth that's a very white name and
uh more people she
you can talk about her boyfriend now
is not helping me because she's 20 she's
scared she doesn't want
her parents to separate
or divorce okay
ma'am we're discussing the rezoning for
the portillos do you have any comments
on that
[Laughter]
dude he let it go so far he let it go
two minutes and 15 seconds and basically
said
ma'am this is dominoes
man we're discussing the re-zoning for
portellos
this is about an italian restaurant why
are you naming
everyone you've ever met
for what we're discussing the rezoning
on 53rd for well i live on 63rd
again we're here to hear comments about
the rezoning well i don't like facebook
oh
oh that is amazing dude
she's gone to lunch already
dude that is amazing well i don't like
facebook dude i'm gonna you that bro
that you know how much [ __ ] that could
get you out of
you know how much [ __ ] if you just stop
everything and say well i don't i i
don't like facebook are you get out of
tickets are you kidding me
you get out of being a father that way
for real a girl's like i'm pregnant
you're like well i don't like facebook
what he lost his mind you're not seeing
my kid
and i don't
like the internet because i can't find a
job
the library blocked my password
now tell me does that make any sense to
you
oh definitely not um this is about we're
not here to discuss your personal life
i'm sorry do you have any comments about
the rezoning no sir have a good day
thank you next
dude
how i'm hal reid
wow wow how do you follow that i'm hal
reed um
so basically i know this guy named greg
i know uh chauncey
uh and then there's four women that i
kind of i just went to lunch with
they're friends with my grandma my
grandma couldn't come but it was ruth um
okay listen this is about the rezoning
of portellos we have to just stop you
don't come up here and just tell me
everyone you know i just met you too i
understand how thank you very much
the [ __ ] is wrong with everyone
city council how about
city council meetings
you know what i mean
just showing up in dockers has anybody
ever not worn dockers at a city council
meeting
no the answer is no
this is another good one
don't mean to make this a clip show i
know you guys do like it next is richard
schwartz
such a city council named richard
good afternoon afternoon oh you could
tell she's already pissed um before you
start the clock could you stop it for a
second
it's real discouraging to come up here
and see all the heads down it's it's
like
you're on a two-minute timer here so
let's go app oh
absolute slam
unreal absolute sl sir you're wasting
valuable seconds yeah in two minutes
first of all he came in just everyone in
this situation is already mad
okay well i'm gonna go up there but
their heads are down if their heads are
down when i get up there you know i
gotta have to say something because you
know how i am right yeah and she was
like i'm having the most [ __ ]
annoying awful day i swear to god if one
person stammers that's docking their
points already
oh he's incredulous right i'm not
following you oh he does he does he does
because i do that move too he does
follow her because i do that move too
and i know that move when when you know
they're when they're making sense but
they're not being nice i'm sorry i don't
follow you what's going on because
there's a protocol here you're supposed
to be nice to somebody and i'm being
nice to you and i'm just casually kind
of seeing what's up and you're not being
nice so no i don't follow you so why
don't we rewind time a little bit like
superman did it when he flew around the
world
hmm
my own super memory in that [ __ ]
christopher reeves movie superman when
he flew around the world you didn't know
how he was gonna save the day because
[ __ ] lois already died so he flew
around the world backwards and he
reversed time so why don't we get
superman to do that because i don't
follow you
you're on a two minute timer slam him
again could you start it over please no
we're not going to just go ahead just so
so angry so it was unreasonable for you
to ask that people look up and give me
their attention sir you have two minutes
we're all looking at you have two
minutes now you have a minute and 30
seconds unreal okay well i guess i won't
be able to
say it um last week you limited uh
this kind of goes to the heart of what i
was going to talk about which was the
state of our democracy all right you've
got one minute left oh [ __ ]
dude goes our state of our democracy the
woman goes
so rude
so rude with a robot
limited speakers because of the number
of speakers to one minute each but you
allowed uh
camilla jayapal to speak as long as you
wanted to it was four or five minutes
and it reminded me of uh george orwell's
famous saying from animal farm about how
all animals are equal but some animals
are more equal than others
i feel like i'm being treated now just
because i forty-five seconds kind of
asking for your attention like i noticed
you all were very attentive to miss
jayapal the other last week
i just wanted to ask your attention
before i started
and
i immediately got a hostile response
back from you i don't understand that
so you don't ever respond to
citizens or what i do sir but you have
two minutes for public comment to the
agenda items
oh man i remember on tape and i think
it's a it's a pretty sad commentary
that you think that asking for you guys
to look up off of your computers and
give attention during this short period
of time was an unreasonable thing
i really feel bad about that
thank you
damn dude
that's [ __ ] up dude but also
some audiences are hard dude
that's why you get those [ __ ]
[ __ ] that go to american idol with
like [ __ ] one of those propeller hats
you know because they're like i'm gonna
make a dif
be nicer dude hey lady in the [ __ ]
thing be nicer otherwise you're going to
get [ __ ] that come up and try and
and and show up and they're going to
think their toasters [ __ ] haunted
this is exactly how you create these
[ __ ]
no one's nice to this lady june o'brien
in the 80s so she's like you know what
one day her brain just went
and she said satan's in my toaster
dude that's literally what happened this
is what happens yes i'm simplifying it
and my therapist no but i get this [ __ ]
dude we need to be nicer to each other
yes we need to have rules yes we need to
[ __ ] abide by them and when someone
crosses them that's not okay but let's
start with niceness
i used to walk into a room and think
that everybody [ __ ] hated me for one
reason or another and i used to think
that ever since i was a little kid is
that my ocd yes sorry god but still
that's what i thought that's what i
thought up until my [ __ ] late 30s
just recently i've been taking a look
inward why the [ __ ] do i think everybody
hates me why do i think that i made that
[ __ ] up all in my head
now when i walk into the coffee bean and
tea leaf i [ __ ] strut because maybe
these people
don't even know who i am how about that
it's not even necessarily that they have
to like me but i'm just being and maybe
they don't even know who i am because
i'll be damned if i'm a [ __ ]
when i turn 90 that thinks his goddamn
toaster's haunted
i do stand up dude i talk to these bad
audiences
i've heard [ __ ] like next
and i just replied with hey you know
that's what happens
whatever the [ __ ] i reply with i'm a
little out of practice
but it's like come on dude let's
be a little bit nicer to each other
so people's brains don't [ __ ] break
got too much brain breaking going on
because of these dicks in congress
put that on my [ __ ] tombstone
what you want on your tombstone
[ __ ] [ __ ] congress they make people's
brains break sir i meant your tombstone
pizza remember that
remember that commercial which one your
tombstone
these [ __ ] idiot commercials wow just
said lead with niceness and now i'm
calling whoever made these commercials
idiots
what says malibu on american gladiators
so this was my patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
uh this was sent by if you're a one fire
level patron
um
you can send me stuff to uh to review
and talk about we have a segment ideas
on the discord uh and this is by mac
delicious
change it uh
by this is malibu
on american gladiators now i haven't
seen this yet but universal studios
hollywood and the american gladiators
now last time we saw our gladiator
malibu he was flying through the air
from a tremendous kick
delivered by brian hudson
and the last time he landed we weren't
sure where he wound up
i mean
after you got oh my god this guy is a
guy this is dog the bounty hunter before
he got [ __ ] old and fat
dude
i love how everything in the 80s was so
grand it was just like universal
studios california dude you know what
it's hilarious and there's still those
guys that are out there
that are uh that are
like doing it because they're old
like like that guy who announces [ __ ]
in the left corner
let's get ready to rumble that guy's old
there's no way a young guy would start
that [ __ ] it's just he's too cool for it
there's no [ __ ] way
he would just be like yeah we got two
boxers let's go guys come on man i'm
[ __ ] live tweeting this
vin scully you know is he still alive
vince scully
wow is it him that does the announcing
still
finally they got rid of him
he he was the only guy no i'm just
saying how long can you do it till
one fire is a huge dodger fan he's like
hey yeah but vince scully was j the side
was retired
just one guy
they always had two guys they had the
color commenter and then the [ __ ]
other boring guy you know
that's why he was amazing is what one
fire's saying that's why he didn't dude
two guys is better than one dude vince
scully was just the dodgers the dodgers
here comes todd zill up to the plate
part of the reason was because it was so
[ __ ] slow the way he talked another
guy would have been you know there were
two guys there but the other guy fell
asleep always
i were with there is another guy here in
the booth with me but
he's fallen asleep
because i talk so slow and he can't get
a word in edgewise
usually it means if someone can't get a
word in edgewise
the person is talking too fast for you
to even comprehend how to interrupt
but for me it's different
for me you can get a word in edgelaw
edgewise
because as i'm talking
this sweet serenade of my tone
puts you completely out so we're gonna
miss strike two
dude he'd always fit it in there
swinging a miss strike two todd's
john ulroad's wife
wouldn't let him out when he was younger
to play baseball
but he loved it so much i'm sorry not
his wife his mom why the [ __ ] his wife
shows that i've got deeper issues
hensley mullins steps up to the plate
swinging a miss strike one ball one
those were just two pitches that went so
fast but i talk so slow you won't be
able to understand
when how quickly the
long fly ball deep to left and he's a
hit ju
[ __ ]
rob dibble
john cruck swinging a miss strike two
one more strike speaking of one
john crock only has one nut because he
had testicular cancer and he's out
that's true junk cruck had [ __ ]
testicular cancer and one time when i
was in high school i got out of a car
and my nuts twisted and this is true
dude i got out of a car my nuts twisted
they hurt so bad wouldn't stop hurting
was embarrassed rob kane said hey what's
wrong and i said i have a tummy ache
because didn't want me to tell him my
nuts twisted went home told my mommy my
nuts twisted she was like what 30
minutes later i was like hey mom my nuts
are still all twisted up she took me to
the hospital they put a [ __ ] whatever
they do to see the babies the ek what is
the thing that they put the goop on
what's it called
ultrasound and then they put the
ultrasound on the [ __ ] on my balls
and she was like oh i got it your
testicle's tortioned
your testicles torsion by getting out of
the suburban with rob kane
[Laughter]
it was after school one day
before basketball practice said
in lchs such as la canada high school
you stepped out of the white suburban
and your balls tortioned
so you had to go down to verdugo hills
hospital and
get ultrasound on your nut sack
[Laughter]
side retired
so i was like my balls are tortioned and
he and the lady was like yeah but the
good thing is is it [ __ ] tortioned
back and i was just like
my [ __ ] balls
auto-corrected themselves
your balls can auto-correct themselves
if you leave it be
i said what happens if they didn't she
literally said we'd have to remove
remove one of them oh thank god they
autocorrected
if your balls didn't autocorrect
have to remove one of them
swatch side
to my face
my mother forgot
the [ __ ] nurse said
with a hand
with a handful of jelly a nurse looked
in my eyes with a hand full of jelly
and another handful ultrasound
and said
if boston torsion back
we have to remove it
so
i'm the john crocker la canada dude
dude thank god your balls switched back
oh dude anyway that was a hell of a
weird run starting from [ __ ] the guy
who used to announce the [ __ ]
universal studios thing let's go back
and watch this guy who was dog the body
100 that lost a lot of weight a human
cannonball i thought hey there is no way
this guy is going to live to play
another day you're alive you're well
what happened did you go to the hospital
did you get x-rays
did you get x-rays did you go to the
barber oh i see you didn't
dude the guy's sunglasses are so big
you can get pulled over wearing them
it's a windshield
[Laughter]
well it's like this oh
dude the most dutical dude of all time
he took off his windshields and said
well dude it's like this oh oh oh this
is my favorite guy dude
the guys oh for [ __ ]
sake
you know goddamn well that this guy
is a trumper a hardcore trumper at this
point
a hardcore like still believes that joe
biden will never be president
you could just you can just you know
that that's his aura
i saw this guy coming
okay and i took the most excellent hit
of my life
the next thing i knew
i was on the beach taking in some cosmic
rays getting healed by mother nature
taking a little brewski holding on a
beautiful babe and i'm fine today
so no hospital
uh 80s
why don't people act like that anymore i
wish there were movies where guys acted
like that still
[ __ ] you know
there's just not
and
and that's it
and that sucks
i miss guys like malibu
doctors just mother nature huh oh i'm a
child of mother nature what do you
expect malibu you are truly amazing she
took a licking and he is a chick that
guy's a chick
that guy's a chick he's a chick dude if
i had to have sex with one guy would be
malibu from american gladiators
uh dude it's like this man
you know i don't want to be happy
i don't want to be having sex with dudes
but if i was gonna dude
what do you expect
in this case it's maligo
[Applause]
but maybe not for long
malibu gets owned
himself
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean used okay enough dude he used the
[ __ ] he has a huge [ __ ] thing and
he's just like yo man
he [ __ ] didn't use the block kicked
him in the [ __ ] head dude
how about that
man you know dude mother nature man
wow malibu got rocked
hey man
um
so yeah
we've been having fun on twitch follow
us on twitch
uh flex avenue
god damn you know cause we had to call
it flex avenue
because your boy's all lumped up dude
not just in his pockets but he's all
lumped the [ __ ] up
oops whoops your boy's lumped up oops
your boy's got a turtle back yeah
[ __ ] worked on my lats earlier dude
it's insane
my [ __ ] [ __ ] i look like one of those
[ __ ] what are you i i i walk down the
street somebody's like is that a [ __ ]
huge flying squirrel no it's just me
dude i got lats it's crazy i'm like one
of those guys who [ __ ] dude the other
day i went to go do a one of those
you know those guys who [ __ ] go
through the
who cares this is not even a good bit
who even gives a [ __ ] it's not even a
good bit it's fine it's just kind of
is what it is
i've been trying to curb my [ __ ] ocd
it's tough man i don't want my my son to
see it and then think that you got to do
it you know
it's a lot i met another guy with ocd
and we were talking about it and he was
like it really opened up to me and it
was like
crazy
his
you know his rituals to me were like wow
that's that's bad and then i was sharing
my rituals and it's like mine are
[ __ ] bad too just in a different way
and it's just like
it's hard to [ __ ] deal with because
you know it's fake like
and it's so too like something that
helps me actually with my ocd is i think
about how egotistical it is like let's
go back to the lady with the toaster who
thought she was so the [ __ ] that satan
was at her house if i walk onto the
plane wrong i think it's gonna crash you
understand but how egotistical is that
i'm in control of everybody on this
plane's
life
what about the way they entered the
plane no it's all about me
you know
it's so egotistical that helps me in a
way because i think like oh that's
[ __ ] i'm just another person on this
world i got to relax my ego's out of
control that i you know my ocd
if i don't [ __ ] throw this snapple
bottle away right then you know my mom's
gonna get cancer or some [ __ ] when
there's no medic metaphysical proof like
that of course it doesn't
have that
happen but like you know that that's not
the truth
because i control people's lives [ __ ]
all that
so that helps me a little bit if you
have ocd that you should think about try
to think about it that way
between that and a little bit of
medication i'm able to [ __ ]
because i i
i was with my my [ __ ] my ex-wife my
first wife um
and she was like
your ocd is getting out of control you
should
you should take medication and i was
like i'm not in my head i was like i'm
never taking medication until it starts
affecting my work
and then one time
i decided one time i was at i was gonna
go on stage at the improv and i was so
stressed out with my ocd and i couldn't
stop thinking about my rituals that i
was like you know what dude
it was right before i went on stage and
i went on stage all like buzzing and
like [ __ ] up in my own head because of
ocd and i was like i'm just gonna
actually
i'm just gonna actually start taking
medication the next day i started taking
medication dude the next day i had pills
already that i didn't take and i started
taking them and i never looked back to
it and it does help the medication with
the like
you know i read about it and i also have
done some behavioral therapy
at one time i took a uh
um i went to behavioral therapy uh and
this guy
was just like i went to him to see him a
few times and he was like you know what
could work for you and i was like what
just take the so what approach
so what if it happens i'm just like huh
and he was like i was like you tell me
if i sm throw the [ __ ] snap a bottle
away
so what my mom's gonna die of cancer and
he was like yeah
now it's just like
gargano dark
so anyway man it's been a long way but
that [ __ ] [ __ ] flares up when you're
22 23.
so i was like how when did it flare up
for you to the
my new buddy and he was like
yeah 22. he was like
i was like there you go
but there were always signs
you know like i said like the sorry god
[ __ ]
or that i lined up my car my matchbox
cars and my uncle vinnie would come over
and he would be like
hey what's this one and i'm like no you
don't take them out you don't take them
out of the [ __ ] order
and my mom was like ooh he doesn't like
when you when you when you move his cars
so yeah but that's it dude you guys are
great um if you you know it really helps
us out subscribe to the youtube channel
uh and [ __ ] absolutely
obliterate that like button into
smithereens and uh take the [ __ ] uh
take the bell notification out for some
for some daytime coffee
you know and uh
that's it we hope you enjoy the patreon
content and we hope you enjoy the uh you
hope you enjoy us playing on twitch
um
and that's it sometimes i do twitch solo
but whatever dude it's all good but uh
come along the board oh oh and i also
gotta say um there the merch out there
we have new merch which is besides this
to be more memorable uh we've got uh
that go out uh go medium and sometimes
stay out because i
which is [ __ ] awesome gym wear
because these [ __ ] at the gym
are all go hard and go home go hard or
go home when it's like nah that's how
you pull a [ __ ] muscle go hard or go
home is how you tear your [ __ ] acl i
saw a fact and also it's out of control
this saying i saw these fat this fat guy
at the coffee bean and tea leaf with a
go hard to go home
shirt on and it's like bro you're not
going hard or going home so
go medium and sometimes stay out and you
live the [ __ ] longer with less pain
so rep that [ __ ] at the gym dude when my
[ __ ] comes in i'm going to the gym i
haven't been to the gym since the
pandemic happened i'm going back to the
gym and preaching to these [ __ ]
go medium
and and stay and sometimes stay out and
there's the merch right there on our
[ __ ] youtube so you could see it um
you guys are great i love my son i love
my i love my people and i saw logic say
this thing the other day and they were
like how come you don't like do
certain [ __ ] and he was just like i
don't [ __ ] with anyone man because i
don't [ __ ] with anyone i [ __ ] with
nobody
i got my family and my friends and i
don't [ __ ] with anyone and i was like
dude i'm practically logic because
that's how i'm gonna be
adoption of himself
hey guys that's the episode for youtube
today if you'd like to extended uncut
rest of the episode head on over to our
patreon patreon.com crystalia we've got
other segments uh one of them is
entitled review mode where i review [ __ ]
you need to know and uh there's also
other behind the scenes stuff i post you
know
daily where where i am and [ __ ] i have
[ __ ] nice pictures of my ice
americano you know what's up but dude
let's get involved get involved with the
life of me um over on patreon.com
crystalia and if you don't we still love
you we love your support whether you're
just viewing or
you're [ __ ] you got no dents and
you're hitting up that patreon thanks a
lot
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
[Music]
okay i'll do the thing now